Ngay bác mối tần từ năm 2018, không chạm hai sấu, không nghĩ giữ vinh nào hóc,
bây quên tham chăm lòng hài, chính thức đi vào hành động.
Với vai trò đối tác chính lượng còn diện của chăm Rúc,
với TVCAP đơn vị thuộc đà trên đi vinh Nam đã phần lịch năng lực công ứng khạp tận vĩ thông,
chuyên thình và giải pháp chuyên thông tổng thị.
Nhằn tổng tư tròn gì giống,
với TVCAP, Vinh dự là đơn vị độc quyền,
cũng có giữ vụ trên đing cáp cho quan bộ 1,2 chăm phòng nghĩ tại đây.
Văn người thế mạnh với TVCAPSOP chính thức vận hành xan hàng bị phẩm cao cấp,
mê li ông tại sạy chính, đồng thời,
TVCAPSOP cũng đảm giận vai trò đại lý phân phối sịch vụ dù lịch và lưu chú.
Đặc biệt, không ra nghệ thuật tại đây sẽ được thắt sáng định kỳ hàng tháng
với các mini show các nhạc.
Này cũng là nơi sẽ dễn ra, đêm chung thách của Ti miss L.S. Việt Nam,
hài nghịn khuốc trọng hài sấu, vào tháng 1 vụ tới.
Sự bắt tay chính lượng sẽ là độc bước quan trọng,
thuốc đời sự phát triển bên vướng trong hành xúc lịch và sĩnh buồn nước nhà.